[Music]
this machine is a StairMaster to mount
the machine you stand on both the steps
provided and then up onto the stairs
to start the machine you press the green
button on the screen and the stairs will
then begin to move
make sure that when you're on this
machine you don't step too close to the
crease of the step so that you don't
trap the front of your foot when
climbing
the speed is shown there on the screen
and to change the speed you push the
button up towards the Plus
to stop the machine from moving you will
then press the big red button on the
handlebar in front of you to stop the
machine you will then Dismount the
machine stepping onto both the steps and
then onto the floor
[Music]